okay
okay time to
regain focus
and i'll go for the same line if he
allows me because i was doing pretty
well out of the opening in my last
white game but we're back to
plus one and this is a serious match
and i've lost my last two black games
without much much of a fight
okay what do i do here
let's go a3
c2
just a normal diamond of sicilian
temple up
so far he's thinking a bit just lovely
find out a lot of people don't play
energetically enough when they're faced
with
these
these sort of systems that you play in
with one more more uh in reverse
that is a great turn
um bishop d6 like normally black would
have castle already if
we have reversed colors
okay i'm just gonna play play it simple
this is system is not a bad one with
reversed collar so
how bad could it be the tempo up
probably not a real attempt but an
advantage but still
very decent i think
no i mean i have two ideas either to go
for e4
uh or to go for bishop d2 to c3
both of them are pretty reasonable
this is a b4 i don't know why uh
whiffed on that opportunity
um there is some to be something to be
said for going h4 here
you know what i kind of like it it has
very little pressure on my
on my center so i think i'm
sort of allowed to play a bit
adventurously
knight a5 is not an issue because i can
just take the forest bracket
as far as i can see knight d4 is not
dangerous either
okay so it's clearly intending queen e6
i think
okay well h5 seems reasonable from a
positional point of view
okay yeah this one
yeah i guess we're h4
trying to gain some time
and he can avoid the exchange of queens
but i don't
know if it will bring in any particular
dividends
okay we'll go g4
just gain some more space
and if b5 i believe rookie 4 was not too
bad
no
i think g5 is not bad
at least i'm getting some more space on
the
fourth rank for my rook
but now he was at f5 that is interesting
okay he is getting a lot of space
so it's not illogical
but i have some ideas of my own
so we go knight h4 and if rook f8 we go
e4
and my knight will establish itself on
f5
so let's say i can play rook f4 probably
no
that's interesting he believes that
he has enough he has enough counterplay
here
[Music]
i'm not sure i can let i can blame him
for holding that belief
i think knight d4 will happen
you know what i i really want to play
dynamically here so i'm just going to go
f4
and if he goes knight d2 e2 king c2
takes him g1 i rook d7 if rook f5 then i
have ef5
and fe5 is happening and it looks like i
have
a lot a lot of play
he goes for it that's interesting
looks
very brave but perhaps it's justified
okay yeah 92 was missed
second c7 okay knight c3 will take back
yeah fe 5 i think it's just too much
never take on c5 s3 i go f6
so i don't think i have any
particular issues
yeah f6
okay second b5
i don't really see why not
i'm getting too short of time to think
too much about it so
i'll just do it
check i think i'll go king
probably can't see without elbow candy
[Music]
of course can't
take
i guess this is fairly dryish now
probably very hard to win now i'm gonna
try
okay checks
oh it was actually a repetition
i was kind of looking before them but i
guess i guess
uh
that was a bit disappointing i thought
i thought i was able to
get some
some chances there